Générique
...
-Bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans "Politiques, à table !"
Heureuse de vous retrouver.
On va parler
alimentation, agriculture,
écologie et politique
pendant une heure avec un invité,
tout particulier cette semaine,
Alexis Michalik, bonjour.
-Bonjour !
-Merci d'être avec nous.
Pour présenter l'émission,
Jean-Pierre Montanay.
-Bonjour à vous deux.
-Bonjour, Jean-Pierre.
-Vous êtes scénariste,
acteur, dramaturge,
metteur en scène, réalisateur
et écrivain,
vous avez remporté
5 Molière, ce qui fait de vous
l'un des metteurs en scène
les plus jeunes
jamais récompensés.
Vous vous êtes lancé
dans la comédie musicale
avec succès, avec "Les producteurs".
Vos 5 pièces attirent les foules.
Vous êtes reconnu dès la 1re,
avec "Le porteur d'histoire",
puis "Le cercle des illusionnistes"
"Edmond", "Intra muros"
et "Une histoire d'amour".
Vous avez fait
de la pièce "Edmond" un film
et écrit en 2019
votre premier roman, "Loin".
On vous a vu
au cinéma dans "Sagan",
"Des gens qui s'embrassent",
"24 jours"
ou dans la série
"Kaboul Kitchen",
petit extrait
de l'étendue de vos talents.
On sait que vous avez
des origines polonaises
par votre papa
et britanniques
par votre maman.
Pourtant,
c'est en Afrique du Nord
que vous nous emmenez
pour ce déjeuner.
-Il y a des liens
avec le Maroc,
parce que c'est un couscous royal
et en dessert,
une salade de fruits,
Brigitte.
-Dans Le dessous des plats,
les Cuistots Migrateurs,
une association
qui aide des chefs
réfugiés en France à s'intégrer,
tout en nous dévoilant
leurs traditions culinaires.
-Le dry january a la cote.
Des restaurants s'y mettent
et proposent des accords mets-vins,
mais sans vin.
-Allez, on passe à table.
Tout de suite,
Cuisine et confidences.
-Alexis Michalik,
vous qui aimez porter
les histoires, voilà un conte
planétaire qui a du sens,
quand vous évoquez à cette table
votre pièce "Passeport" qui raconte
le quotidien de la jungle de Calais,
l'histoire
d'une petite graine, le couscous.
Pour être cohérent,
il fallait aujourd'hui
célébrer un plat
qui traverse les frontières
sans passeport.
Voilà pourquoi
vous nous proposez ce totem
de la cuisine multiculturelle,
universelle,
inscrit au patrimoine
immatériel de l'UNESCO.
D'origine berbère,
il naît au Maghreb,
mais s'est enrichi au fil des ans.
Avec l'essor
de la civilisation arabe,
des épices comme la cannelle,
puis la viande
vont s'inviter dans la recette.
A partir du 11e siècle,
il séduit le Moyen-Orient.
En France,
Rabelais l'évoque dès 1542,
mais nous le découvrons vraiment
dans les années 60,
grâce aux vagues d'immigration
venues d'Afrique du nord.
Il figure chaque année
dans le top 5
de nos plats préférés.
Le couscous est-il
un choix politique ?
Vous pensez vraiment que la cuisine
peut aider à faire reculer
les préjugés racistes
et la peur de l'étranger ?
-Si seulement !
Si seulement
ça pouvait être le cas !
Il me semble même avoir le souvenir
que certains députés RN
ont eu des ennuis
pour avoir mangé un couscous,
c'est dire,
de leur propre électorat.
-Jean-Marie Le Pen,
c'est son plat préféré.
-On leur reprochait d'aller
à l'ennemi, donc l'étranger.
Non, c'est surtout un choix
gastronomique, d'abord,
parce que j'adore le couscous,
il est fait
avec des légumes bouillis
et c'est pas le cas
de beaucoup de plats en France.
J'adore cette composition.
Là, on a choisi un couscous royal,
avec absolument toutes les viandes.
C'est un peu une hérésie
pour mes amis marocains,
j'ai une copine
qui me reproche souvent de manger
des merguez avec le couscous,
car ce n'est pas du tout
comme ça qu'on le mange.
-C'est pas du tout
dans les codes
du vrai couscous.
Vous avez un souvenir
d'un couscous d'enfance,
votre premier couscous ?
-Pas particulièrement.
Après, je rétorquerai
quand même à mon amie
qu'elle mange bien
des sushis california,
qui n'ont rien à voir
avec les sushis de base.
Une culture s'additionne
d'autres cultures
et c'est comme ça qu'on arrive
à cette magnifique assiette
de couscous royal.
-On va le goûter.
-Il commence à être froid.
Moi, j'y vais.
Il est incroyable.
Vous l'avez trouvé où, Brigitte ?
-C'est le restaurant Essaouira,
à Paris,
qui nous l'a confectionné.
Vous pouvez peut-être nous dire
trois choses sur le couscous royal ?
-Oui, même si j'ai été
spoilé par Alexis.
C'est un fin connaisseur
et amoureux du couscous.
Symbole de sa parfaite intégration,
le couscous royal
est en fait
une pure invention française,
qui figure à la carte
de restaurants très français,
à côté d'un boeuf bourguignon
ou d'une blanquette.
En principe, le couscous
traditionnel, je parle
sous le contrôle d'Alexis,
se caractérise
par une seule viande :
mouton, poulet, boeuf,
méchoui,
ou alors poisson,
notamment en Tunisie,
qui a un couscous de poisson.
Le couscous royal porte bien
son nom,
car il réunit toutes ces viandes
en un même plat, sans oublier
le mélange d'épices
ras el-hanout.
Le couscous royal y ajoute
des boulettes
et aussi ces merguez qui font hurler
les puristes de la graine.
Ils parlent d'hérésie.
Jamais vous ne trouverez
une merguez
dans les trois couscous
du Maghreb :
Algérie, Maroc, Tunisie,
mais Alexis aime les merguez,
donc on a un couscous royal !
-Vous dégustez
ce couscous, on voit
que ça vous fait très, très plaisir.
Ca nous fait, du coup,
immensément plaisir.
Vous le trouvez bon ?
-Il est pas mal.
Il est pas très chaud,
mais ça, c'est les contraintes
de l'émission.
Mais il est bon. J'ai rajouté
une bonne dose de harissa.
-Vous aimez quand c'est relevé ?
-De plus en plus.
C'est vraiment le plat
de cet hiver.
J'en ai mangé peut-être
un jour sur deux.
Mes acteurs se moquent de moi
parce que je suis obsédé
par le couscous.
Je suis ravi de le partager
avec vous.
-Tous les deux jours,
couscous royal ?
-Pas forcément,
ça dépend. J'adore les merguez,
effectivement,
ça relève un peu le plat,
y a un petit côté épicé,
un petit peu piquant,
qui va contraster
avec la douceur de la sauce,
avec les raisins.
C'est pas forcément...
C'est un petit ajout à nous.
-Ah,
au Maroc, il y a parfois
ces raisins un peu sucrés.
-Oui, parfois.
-Et les pois chiches.
-J'ai vécu presque un an
au Maroc,
je tournais dans une série,
"Kaboul Kitchen",
qui se tournait à Casablanca.
Donc...
-C'était Maroc tous les jours.
-Mais pas couscous,
parce que c'est pas non plus...
Là-bas, c'est un truc familial.
C'est le plat de famille,
on le mange pas
dans les restos.
-C'est un plat de fête ?
-C'est un plat du vendredi soir,
c'est un plat du moment
où on se retrouve.
-Là-bas, on le mange à la main ?
-Pas forcément.
-Pas forcément ?
C'est pas la tradition ancestrale.
-Mais c'est le plat de famille,
chacun a son couscous,
chaque maman a son couscous.
-Vous mangiez des tajines,
des pastillas ?
-Des tajines,
c'est plutôt ça
dans les restos au Maroc.
-La salade de carottes au cumin.
-Effectivement,
du cumin un peu partout.
J'ai adoré,
et puis j'en ai trop mangé.
Maintenant, j'ai un petit...
Trop de cumin tue le cumin.
Ils en mettent partout.
-Il n'y a pas de rejet du couscous
si vous en mangez aussi souvent ?
Vous n'en avez pas ras-le-bol ?
-Je pense que le couscous,
on ne s'en lasse jamais,
parce que, d'abord,
les légumes.
Ce qui fait un bon couscous,
c'est la variété des légumes.
Là, il y a pas de céleri.
Or, le céleri,
c'est un peu
la facilité du couscoussier cheap.
Le céleri, c'est pas trop cher,
on en met plein.
Quand vous recevez un couscous
et qu'il y en a plein...
-C'est pas bon signe ?
-Ca coûte moins cher
que là, où on voit
qu'il y a des courgettes...
-Des carottes,
des navets,
un peu de pommes de terre.
-Il y a du potiron, parfois.
-Ca, c'est une des variantes,
du coup ?
-Au Maghreb,
parfois...
C'est un peu oublié en France,
on en mangeait à Lyon,
c'est le cardon,
et dans certains couscous
maghrébins, il y a du cardon.
C'est une espèce de plante
avec une tige un peu dure,
qui se cuisine. A Lyon,
on le faisait en gratin.
Souvent, on le retrouve
dans les couscous
au Maghreb.
-Mais non, voilà, c'est...
C'est délicieux.
-Les viandes sont bonnes,
il souffre d'être tiède
mais il est bon.
-C'est une bonne adresse.
-Le seul truc,
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de sucre
dans la sauce.
Ce serait parfait
mais elle est très sucrée.
-C'est un peu calorique ?
-Un poil calorique
si on rajoute, comme moi,
deux louches de sauce.
-C'est un plat
que vous mangiez
quand vous étiez petit ?
Vos parents en faisaient
à la maison ?
-Je l'ai vraiment découvert
plus tard,
et aujourd'hui,
je vis une belle histoire d'amour
avec ce couscous.
-Vous savez le préparer ?
C'est tout un truc,
surtout la semoule.
C'est un savoir-faire.
Vous avez appris ?
Ca vous intéresse ?
-Je suis une quiche en cuisine.
-Et on vous a invité.
-Absolument, c'est pour ça.
Pour me nourrir,
merci de m'accueillir.
-Pour connaître vos astuces,
vos petits trucs.
-Exactement.
Je n'ai jamais préparé
le couscous,
mais c'est quelque chose à faire.
Vous savez faire
le couscous ?
-J'avoue
que je ne sais pas.
-J'arrive pas à faire
de la semoule fine.
C'est souvent un travail de femme,
c'est le patriarcat ?
-Les femmes faisaient ça.
-Elles roulent la semoule.
Il faut un couscoussier
mais on peut se débrouiller.
Il faut plusieurs cuissons,
il faut que la vapeur monte.
Il faut mélanger,
on se brûle les doigts
en mettant les mains
pour séparer.
Il faut rajouter,
ce que m'avaient dit
des cuisinières,
à la fin, de l'huile d'olive
plutôt que du beurre
parce que le beurre peut rancir
un petit peu
alors que l'huile d'olive
ne prend pas de petit goût.
C'est une astuce.
-Bon tip.
-Alors,
si vous êtes pas en cuisine,
s'il n'y a rien à manger,
vous savez quand même
vous préparer un oeuf au plat ?
Une boîte de conserve ?
-Oui, quand même, bien sûr.
Je sais faire le minimum,
mais il se trouve
que je vais beaucoup au resto,
je suis toujours avec des amis,
j'ai une grande bande de potes.
Si je suis pas au resto,
je commande beaucoup à manger,
à tel point
qu'une célèbre enseigne
d'une app de livraison
de nourriture
m'a déjà proposé deux fois
"des solutions
pour mon entreprise"
alors que c'est juste moi
qui commande.
Je commande souvent
pour de grandes tablées.
-Peut-être qu'ils voudraient
vous avoir
pour vendre leur plate-forme.
-Ma consommation suffit
à leur faire 30 %
de leur chiffre d'affaires.
-Vous êtes jeune,
vous devriez être déconstruit !
-Vous êtes gentil.
Au niveau de la cuisine ?
Ca n'a rien à voir
avec un quelconque sexisme
mais plutôt avec mes habilités
personnelles.
-Vous êtes gourmand
mais vous ne voulez pas le faire
vous-même ?
Vous avez pas de temps
parce que vous avez beaucoup trop
de boulot ?
-Euh, non, je pense que...
-Parce que vous faites plaisir
à voir, là.
Vous êtes un des rares invités
qui se soucient du plat.
-Vous prenez du plaisir.
-La régie son doit avoir
un grand plaisir à entendre
ma mastication.
Mais il ne fallait pas m'inviter
à manger un couscous.
-Vous avez de bonnes adresses
à conseiller
en matière de couscous ?
-Moi, j'ai mon petit pref'.
Il se trouve que...
On va parler
de "Passeport", qui se joue
au théâtre de la Renaissance
à Strasbourg-Saint-Denis,
et là-bas,
il y a le Bec Fin,
chez Saïd,
juste à côté, et qui est...
C'est vraiment gratos,
mais je l'aime
particulièrement.
-Si nos spectateurs y vont,
il va quand même falloir payer.
-C'est un petit coup de pub,
c'était inattendu.
-C'est votre cantine, du coup ?
-Des fois,
je me fais livrer chez eux.
Des fois, j'y vais.
Ils ont un couscous méchoui,
c'est pas une pièce,
c'est une espèce de pavé énorme,
délicieux, grillé comme il faut.
Au Bec Fin, chez Saïd.
-Toute la troupe
aime le couscous,
ou vous leur imposez ça ?
De force, ils sont obligés ?
-Absolument.
On varie un peu, des fois,
mais...
Parfois, on va chercher thaï,
libanais,
et le couscous, ils savent
que c'est ma passion.
Je n'aime pas manger seul,
je régale un peu.
-Vous êtes le roi de la merguez,
mais n'oublions pas
le poisson.
En Tunisie,
il y a le couscous de poisson
et le couscous au poulpe.
Vous avez déjà goûté ?
-Non.
-C'est sur l'île de Kerkennah,
la grande île tunisienne,
Là, il y a un poulpe
au couscous
et un couscous de poisson.
-Moi, le poulpe,
on le faisait...
On le faisait autrement.
Figurez-vous
que quand j'étais jeune,
on allait en vacances en Grèce,
souvent,
tous les étés,
et je pêchais le poulpe
avec mon masque et mon tuba.
Ma mère préparait
un...
Ce qu'on appelle l'oktapodi stifado,
une espèce de poulpe
à l'étouffée avec des oignons.
On mangeait le fruit de la pêche.
C'est comme ça qu'on le faisait,
et mon père,
qui est artiste-peintre,
plasticien,
il utilisait le poulpe,
il prenait des morceaux de...
Il prenait sa propre encre,
il la macérait
et il plaquait... Pardon,
excusez-moi, c'est le couscous.
Sur des toiles blanches,
il arrivait
il arrivait à faire des oeuvres
en utilisant
le poulpe.
-L'encre de seiche, presque.
-L'encre de poulpe,
absolument,
qui est un poil différente
mais non moins efficace.
Et voilà, le poulpe avait
un cycle complet d'utilisation.
-Par toute la famille.
-C'est à Kerkennah
qu'on fait ce couscous.
-Vous parlez
de cuisine du monde,
mais pas du tout
de la cuisine française,
la cuisine du terroir.
Elle vous plaît moins ?
Vous êtes lassé ?
-En fait,
j'y a été moins habitué,
ne serait-ce que parce que ma mère
est anglaise,
et elle cuisinait non pas
de la cuisine anglaise
mais méditerranéenne.
Mes parents se sont rencontrés
en Grèce dans les années 70.
Je pense
qu'ils ont toujours eu
une âme de voyageurs
et d'ouverture
culinaire
et de manière générale.
Donc effectivement,
ma mère adore cuisiner
plutôt des baklavas,
des plats méditerranéens,
des tomates farcies...
-Des poivrons farcis ?
-Exactement.
Et la cuisine anglaise,
c'était ma grand-mère anglaise,
chez qui on allait à Noël.
-Qu'est-ce qu'elle préparait ?
-Pour un Français,
ça existe,
la gastronomie britannique ?
-Ouais, ouais.
Non, c'est une dinde rôtie
avec des légumes rôtis,
des panais, des carottes.
Un de mes plats préférés
est anglais,
un gigot d'agneau avec deux sauces,
une sauce déglacée
et une sauce à la menthe.
Je vous le conseille,
c'est un délice.
L'agneau est une de mes viandes
préférées. Avec une sauce déglacée,
une sauce à la menthe,
des patates rôties,
des haricots verts,
c'est extraordinaire.
La gastronomie anglaise
existe et...
-Et la gastronomie polonaise ?
Il y a des choses
qu'on peut découvrir ?
-C'est plus riche.
-Mon grand-père
est arrivé de Pologne
à 2 ans,
donc il a émigré...
Son père a émigré de Pologne
en 1926,
donc il a grandi en France.
Il y avait pas une tradition
culinaire polonaise qui est arrivée
jusqu'à ma génération.
Mon père, ils se sont implantés
dans le nord,
vers Maubeuge,
dans une région
où il y avait pas grand-chose.
Mon arrière-grand-père était
agriculteur.
Quelques plats du nord ont survécu.
Mon père faisait...
Mon père cuisine,
il fait un fricot de chou rouge
depuis longtemps.
Fricot de chou rouge
avec des patates,
des grosses saucisses,
un truc qui tient bien au corps,
un plat d'hiver.
Et c'est à peu près tout.
A part ça,
j'ai pas de lien
avec la cuisine traditionnelle.
On mangeait pas vraiment
des plats...
J'ai toujours eu cet amour
de l'extérieur,
des cuisines du monde.
-De la curiosité, en tout cas.
-Ouais, ouais.
Cuisine et autres.
-Et l'Asie ?
On a parlé d'Afrique du nord,
là, on a compris,
et la Grèce.
Et l'Asie aussi, vous êtes...
-Ouais,
l'Asie, moi...
Ado, c'était les premiers
restaurants sushi.
C'est pas comme aujourd'hui
où il y en a partout,
c'était vraiment particulier
de manger des sushis, au début.
J'ai adoré.
Et encore une fois,
aujourd'hui, je suis fan
de toute...
De toutes ces gastronomies.
-Chine, Vietnam,
Inde aussi ?
-Oui, je connais
une entrepreneuse,
Céline Chung, qui a créé
Bao Family à Paris.
-C'est formidable, oui.
-J'adore, il y a...
Moi, je me régale,
et par-dessus tout,
ce que j'aime,
c'est le côté un peu mezze,
tapas.
-Pour le partage,
pour l'ambiance ?
-Absolument, et pour goûter.
Je suis allé beaucoup de fois
au Liban,
je suis aussi allé beaucoup
en Israël,
qui est similaire
sur plein d'aspects.
Ces cuisines méditerranéennes
mettent
à l'honneur les légumes,
rendent le légume sexy.
Vraiment,
on utilise des aubergines,
on utilise des patates douces,
on rajoute
des sauces, et ça...
J'ai découvert
qu'on pouvait manger végétarien
mais que ce soit
un mélange de saveurs.
-J'ai un conseil,
Brigitte sera d'accord :
achetez le livre d'Ottolenghi
et mettez-vous...
-Vous croyez que je l'ai pas ?
-Vous cuisinez pas,
ouvrez-les !
-Je fais quelques cuisines.
J'exagère, je fais pas le couscous
mais quand même.
-Il est modeste.
-J'ai "Simple" d'Ottolenghi.
-"Jérusalem", aussi.
-C'est pas si simple !
C'est vrai. Mais il y a en tout cas
plein de recettes,
d'inspiration israélienne,
turque, c'est assez...
Vous faites attention,
quand vous consommez,
à manger moins de viande ?
Là, il y en a beaucoup.
C'est moins bien pour le climat,
pour des raisons écologiques
ou de bien-être animal.
Les légumes que vous aimez,
vous vous dites
qu'il faut consommer
plus bio ou local ?
-Oui.
C'est ironique de dire ça
quand je mange ce couscous,
mais je suis pas un gros viandard.
Au restaurant,
je commande pas de la viande
rouge,
c'est pas mon premier truc.
La viande que je consomme le plus,
c'est du poulet.
Hé non, j'adore,
le soir, pouvoir manger
que des légumes, ça me convient.
Sauf qu'en restauration,
c'est assez difficile
de trouver des plats...
De plus en plus,
il y a des plats végétariens,
mais dans un restaurant,
on a plutôt tendance à avoir
des frites
qu'une vraie variété
de plats à base de légumes.
Je suis persuadé,
et c'est de notoriété publique,
que la santé
s'en porterait mieux.
-On va voir si vous êtes incollable.
C'est le quiz.
-Avec ce sang britannique
qui coule dans vos veines,
vous êtes sans doute
accro au fish and chips.
Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations sont vraies
ou fausses. Affirmation A.
-Oui, ça me semble possible.
-Vrai.
Mais Manchester, Dundee
et Dublin revendiquent la paternité
du fish and chips.
B !
-Je vais dire vrai.
-Non, c'est d'origine juive.
C'est mentionné dans un livre
de cuisine anglaise du 18e siècle.
Affirmation C.
-Vrai ou faux ?
J'aurais tendance à dire
que c'est Belgique,
mais je vais me tromper.
-Alors, je parlais du Royaume-Uni.
-Au Royaume-Uni ?
Oui, c'est possible.
-C'est arrivé
en Grande-Bretagne au début
du 19e siècle.
-C'était les plus pauvres,
les Irlandais.
-Entre les deux guerres,
l'âge d'or du fish and chips,
l'aiglefin était le poisson roi
qui était consommé
dans ces commerces.
-Je sais que c'est le "cod",
mais je sais pas la traduction.
-Non.
-C'est du cabillaud ?
-C'était le cabillaud, bravo !
Ca fait 3 réponses sur 4 ?
-C'est pas mal.
Deuxième quiz,
on va voir si vous êtes fort.
Les hommes de théâtre sont friands
de tirades ciselées et de cuisine.
Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations sont vraies.
-Le parmesan ?
-Vrai ou faux ?
-Ca me semblerait étonnant.
Il y en avait déjà ?
-C'est vrai. Incroyable.
Vous êtes sûr de la réponse ?
-Qui vous a dit que le parmesan
était son préféré ?
-Ne me parlez pas
quand j'ingère la boulette !
-Si, justement !
-A quel moment ?
A quel moment ?
Comment vous le savez ?
-Je l'ai lu et je l'ai vu.
Le parmesan est un très vieux
fromage italien.
A cette époque,
les mets circulaient.
Il n'y avait pas de mondialisation,
et encore,
mais pour Molière,
c'est son préféré.
-Ah bon ?
-Shakespeare considérait
que le thé était
la boisson reine.
-Ca m'étonnerait.
Le thé, ça vient d'Inde,
c'est un peu plus tard.
-Faux, la bière !
La bière, bien sûr !
-Il l'appelait le mets
des rois,
c'était son expression.
-C'était beaucoup plus sûr de boire
de la bière que de l'eau.
On avait moins de chance
d'avoir une maladie,
Tout le monde était,
au Moyen Age, bourré,
le soir.
On consommait plus de bière
que d'eau. Ou le vin.
-Les grandes expéditions mettaient
du vin dans les soutes.
-L'alcool tuait les microbes.
-En revanche,
le thé, c'est ma boisson.
Je ne bois que du thé
à tous les repas.
-A tous les repas ?
-Chez moi, je me fais...
Je ne bois pas d'alcool.
Du coup, de tous les thés,
je me fais des grandes infusions,
soit infusion, soit thé.
J'aime le Earl Grey le matin.
-C'est vos origines britanniques.
-Les thés parfumés, il y en a plein.
Je les fais refroidir,
je les mets
dans des grandes carafes.
-Glacé aussi, avec des glaçons ?
-Froid, parfois,
avec de la menthe, du citron.
Mes amis savent que chez moi,
dans le frigo,
il y a des jarres de thé froid.
-On poursuit avec le canard.
-Je sais pas, je vais dire oui.
-Non, c'était son péché mignon.
-Il adorait le canard.
C'est un peu gras, le canard.
J'ai un peu de mal.
-Et quand on le prépare
à la maison...
-C'est pas gras,
Simplement, la peau de canard,
si elle est grasse,
on peut l'enlever.
Si vous enlevez le gras,
c'est maigre.
-Ca a moins d'intérêt.
-C'est le gras qui va donner
ce goût, je suis d'accord,
mais sachez aussi
que c'est un bon gras.
Il faut mieux manger
de la peau de canard
que de la graisse de porc.
-Le lobby du canard
paie très cher cette émission.
-C'est pas le lobby du canard,
il y a eu des recherches
sur le foie gras.
La graisse de canard a un peu
les mêmes vertus que l'huile
d'olive.
Mangez de la graisse de canard
et du canard sans...
-Si je mange de la graisse
de canard,
je dois faire une sieste.
Ca me fait dormir.
Mais je ne veux pas rentrer...
Je veux pas vexer les canards.
-Ca a plombé l'ambiance.
On continue !
-Poulet à la ficelle ?
Je sais pas pour ce poulet,
je sais pour l'omelette
aux huîtres,
dont il était fan.
Ma mère est fan d'Alexandre Dumas,
et je lui ai offert
les recettes d'Alexandre Dumas,
où il raconte un peu...
-Et le poulet à la ficelle
est dans le livre ?
-Ca doit y être, non ?
-Hé bah c'est vrai.
Hé bah c'est vrai.
-Et donc quoi ?
Il l'entourait ?
-Non, il le suspendait
et tous les orifices étaient
bouchés.
Il le pendait le croupion
en l'air.
-C'était un gros mangeur.
On mangeait dans des proportions
différentes.
-C'est souvent autour de la table
que se racontent les histoires,
que se font les histoires.
C'est la brève de comptoir.
On vous a demandé de réfléchir
à une anecdote
autour d'un repas.
Vous pouvez nous raconter
quelque chose ?
-J'aurais bien aimé,
parce que c'est ma passion,
le repas.
J'en ai 1000,
mais je n'ai pas d'anecdote
particulièrement politique.
Mais ce que je peux vous dire,
et c'est un segment vers ma pièce,
puisque,
souvent, c'est autour de la table
que les sujets politiques
et que les engueulades arrivent.
Qui n'a pas été,
au cours d'une fête de famille,
dans une engueulade
avec une génération différente ?
Avec un point de vue
réactionnaire
et l'autre
un peu plus progressiste.
En général,
je suis du côté progressiste.
Dans "Passeport",
l'une des scènes centrales
de la pièce,
ça parle des réfugiés
et de l'arrivée
des réfugiés en France
mais ça parle aussi
de l'autre côté.
On va suivre un gendarme,
Lucas, qui est noir,
qui a été adopté
par un couple de Calaisiens,
Michel et Christine.
Et Michel est un ancien militaire,
un petit peu raide,
un petit peu réac,
et...
Lucas, ce gendarme, va rencontrer
une journaliste, Jeanne,
qui est noire aussi,
de parents maliens,
et qui est beaucoup plus politisée,
qui a fait son chemin
vers l'identité, et qui va
pousser Lucas à se poser
quelques questions. Il est neutre
et ayant grandi à Calais,
dans un environnement
principalement blanc. Un jour,
à table...
-Avec la jungle de Calais.
-Oui, lui, il est gendarme
et son job, c'est de retenir
les réfugiés
qui essayent de passer
en Angleterre.
C'est la seule fonction
des gendarmes à ce moment-là.
Un soir, il emmène Jeanne à dîner
pour la présenter à ses parents,
en ayant omis de dire à Michel
que Jeanne était noire aussi.
Et Michel va se retrouver
un peu perturbé,
et va s'ensuivre une discussion
sur le sujet de l'immigration.
Je vous laisse imaginer
quels arguments
chaque camp va avoir.
Jeanne a étudié le sujet
et va démonter les idées reçues
de Michel, à grands coups
de chiffres et d'exactitudes.
Du coup, c'est une sorte
de métaphore...
Enfin, pas de métaphore,
mais d'exemple
d'une conversation
qu'on peut retrouver,
si tant est qu'en face
de ces idées reçues habituelles,
on ait vraiment
une source documentée et très claire
sur ce qu'est l'immigration,
sur ce qu'elle apporte à la société
et sur...
Ses bienfaits
et son aspect positif.
-Comment se termine ce repas
entre Jeanne et Lucas ?
-Le ton monte.
Pour avoir la fin,
il faut venir voir la pièce.
-Vous nous faites une transition,
vous avez écrit et mis en scène
"Passeport",
qui se joue depuis
le 26 janvier
à Paris,
où Issa, jeune Erythréen
laissé pour mort à Calais
entame une longue quête
afin d'obtenir un titre de séjour.
Sa seule mémoire est son passeport.
Vous avez un partenaire,
l'association
des Cuistots Migrateurs,
l'occasion de parler
de l'intégration par la cuisine
dans le dessous des plats.
-Ils viennent d'Afghanistan,
d'Irak, de Syrie, du Mali,
du Sri Lanka.
Arrivés en France,
ces réfugiés aux talents de chef,
de cuisinier, font partager
leur tradition culinaire
et leur culture
dans ces Cuistots Migrateurs.
Service traiteur
mais aussi école de cuisine,
solidaires, écologiques...
Tout ça est né en 2015.
C'est un reportage
à Montreuil de Clément Perrault
et Cléa Jouanneau.
-Le monde entier
en cuisine.
Chez les Cuistots Migrateurs,
traiteur installé à Montreuil,
tous les chefs et cuisiniers sont,
ou ont été, des demandeurs d'asile.
Chacun est venu ici
avec sa recette
pour composer une carte hétéroclite.
-Les Cuistots migrateurs
se présentent
comme une entreprise sociale.
Ici, les cuisiniers
sont embauchés en CDI
en CDD. L'idée est d'aider
à leur intégration
en leur fournissant
un travail fixe.
-Bon courage.
L'idée nous est venue
à l'automne 2015.
On a vraiment, tout simplement,
été rattrapés par l'actualité.
La crise migratoire était
un sujet quotidien,
les migrants toujours présentés
comme un poids, une menace.
C'est une question complexe,
on a voulu montrer qu'il y avait
du positif dans tout ça,
qu'on pouvait créer du positif
quand on donnait la chance
aux gens
de montrer
ce qu'ils apportaient.
-Plats exotiques, fibre sociale :
la recette est gagnante.
Les entreprises font appel
au traiteur
pour leur cocktail et buffet.
Depuis 4 ans, il y a également
une école de cuisine,
basée sur le même concept.
200 élèves, tous réfugiés,
suivent les cours.
Aujourd'hui,
la séance de travaux
porte sur la préparation
d'une pâte à nouille.
-On agglomère, on réunit.
A vous.
Prenez chacun une balance,
200 grammes de farine,
2 oeufs par personne,
une pincée de sel.
-Beaucoup de ces élèves
n'étaient pas
cuisiniers avant d'arriver,
comme Maya, syrienne.
-J'étais journaliste.
J'ai décidé de me lancer
en cuisine.
C'est culturel,
c'est le partage.
Voilà.
-Ils sont motivés.
Leur niveau de français
est bon, ils ont eu un mois
avec une prof avant d'arriver ici.
Une fois qu'ils auront leur titre,
ils pourront aller sur le terrain,
ils pourront vite choper
un poste, et du coup, ensuite,
avoir un appartement,
et tout ce qui s'ensuit,
s'intégrer à la France.
-85 % des élèves trouvent
un emploi durable
à la sortie de cette formation.
-Alexis,
comment vous les avez découverts ?
Ca remonte à quelques années ?
A leur naissance
ou c'est récent ?
-Au moment où on a mis la pièce
en chantier,
il se trouve que...
Donc, on va suivre Issa,
ce réfugié érythréen,
et sa tentative
d'intégration en France.
Quand on n'a pas encore
de papiers,
y a pas 1000 options, et donc...
Ils peuvent travailler
sur des chantiers,
au noir,
ils peuvent se retrouver
à travailler
dans des entreprises
de livraison de nourriture.
Souvent, ils sont en cuisine.
Donc Issa et ses amis vont
se retrouver en cuisine,
dans l'univers de la restauration
et apporter
aussi leurs origines,
leur culture au monde
de la cuisine,
et peut-être ouvrir
un restaurant.
On s'est dit
que ce serait chouette
de tendre la main
à des associations,
ou en tout cas
à des...
Des associations, des structures
qui vont dans le sens
de la pièce,
pour que les gens,
en sortant de la pièce, se disent :
"Tiens, ce sujet m'a touché,
"vers qui je peux me tourner ?"
On met des pistes.
On a un partenariat
avec le Musée de l'immigration,
ce qui est super,
et ensuite, ça nous semblait logique
d'amener les Cuistots Migrateurs.
-Ca veut dire quoi ?
Ils proposent une alimentation
à la sortie du théâtre ?
-Déjà, ils ont fait le pot
de première,
mais dans l'idée,
ils vont mettre en place...
Il y a un petit bar,
on va pouvoir vendre
des planches avec leurs...
-Pas de la charcuterie,
des plats syriens ?
-Qu'avez-vous mangé ?
C'est bon ?
-Oui,
c'est délicieux.
Après, il y a les goûts personnels.
Là, ils parlent
de brochettes d'aneth.
Moi, l'aneth, je peux pas.
Mais y a plein de trucs.
Oui, c'est comme ça.
Y a plein de trucs super bons,
c'est un mélange
de plats simples mais de plein...
-Le chiffre 8
est le symbole des Cuistots,
il y a 8 cultures
qui sont
représentées par les recettes
culinaires.
-La cuisine, c'est un...
Le meilleur moyen d'intégration,
pour vous ?
-Encore une fois,
j'aimerais bien que ça soit
le meilleur moyen.
C'en est un, en tout cas.
Et pour eux, c'est l'une
de leurs seules options.
On en a vu une, dans le reportage,
qui était journaliste en Syrie.
C'est le cas de beaucoup,
c'est une idée reçue à combattre,
cette idée qu'ils arrivent
et qu'ils ne sont pas qualifiés.
Si, si,
ils sont qualifiés.
-Il faut maîtriser la langue.
-C'est une grosse barrière,
et il ne faut pas oublier
que les réfugiés qui veulent passer
en Angleterre,
qui se retrouvent à Calais,
c'est ceux qui n'ont pas
la langue française,
pour rejoindre leur famille
ou parce qu'ils parlent anglais.
L'Angleterre paye la France
pour les empêcher
de passer.
Ils sont dans une situation où,
après avoir traversé
des milliers de kilomètres,
ils sont bloqués à Calais
et ils se disent :
"Qu'est-ce que je fais ?"
Et c'est le début
du parcours du combattant.
Cyrielle est journaliste
mais elle se met à la cuisine
et elle est passionnée.
-Elle transmet sa culture.
-Ils peuvent aussi se réaliser
dans ce métier.
-Bien sûr.
-Mais ça oblige à changer.
-Quand on est docteur en Syrie
ou architecte en Irak
et qu'on se retrouve cuistot,
ça peut être mal vécu.
-Imaginez vous retrouver
dans un pays
dont vous ne maîtrisez pas
la langue
parce que la guerre a éclaté
et vous êtes parti
sans savoir
si vous allez revenir un jour,
et vous vous retrouvez
dans un pays
où vous faites la cuisine...
-Jean-Pierre est
le meilleur d'entre nous
en cuisine.
Il va se fondre
dans le décor.
-La cuisine,
si on n'est pas à la plonge,
si on peut transmettre ça,
c'est un métier passionnant.
Les chefs qu'on reçoit,
ils sont passionnés.
Et on sent dans les yeux
de Cyrielle qu'elle est passionnée
par son nouveau métier.
-Nous allons regarder
un petit extrait des répétitions
de votre pièce "Passeport".
-It only takes one wave to die
Musique mélancolique
...
On va la voir
un peu plus tard.
Pourquoi vous avez décidé de traiter
ce sujet de l'immigration ?
On est dans une actualité très forte
en ce moment, sur ce thème-là.
-Déjà, je pars jamais d'un thème.
Je me suis pas dit :
"Je vais parler de ça."
Je pars toujours de l'histoire,
et l'histoire m'est arrivée
il y a trois ans,
j'étais en Guadeloupe et j'ai eu
l'idée de la fin de la pièce,
que je ne vais pas
dévoiler évidemment,
mais cette fin m'a fait remonter
le cours de cette histoire
et la construire à rebours,
et je me suis dit :
"Il faudrait que ça commence
dans la jungle de Calais."
C'est un endroit que
je ne connaissais pas très bien,
enfin pas plus que ce que
tout le monde croit en savoir.
-Vous y êtes allé ?
-Non, elle a été démantelée
et je m'intéressais
à la période
2015-2016,
au pic de sa fréquentation,
où il y avait entre 6000
et 10 000 réfugiés.
Mais j'ai commencé
à lire des témoignages, des sites,
des bouquins sur le sujet,
sur Calais, sur les réfugiés,
sur l'immigration en France
et l'immigration en général
dans le monde,
et au fur et à mesure
se dessinait
une pensée plus précise
des sujets que je voulais aborder
et au début,
d'une histoire simple
de vouloir suivre un réfugié,
c'est devenu
quelque chose de plus large,
essayer d'aborder un prisme
de différentes personnes racisées
à différents degrés d'intégration
en France.
C'est comme ça qu'ont commencé
à se dessiner
mon thème et mon histoire.
Et comme j'ai l'impression
d'être simplement touché
par le sujet, pour diverses raisons,
d'abord, par le fait
de mes origines multiples qui,
même si elles ne sont pas visibles,
et c'est toute la différence
parce que je n'ai jamais souffert
du racisme,
il n'empêche que j'ai grandi
dans un quartier
à la fois populaire
et multiculturel,
le 18e arrondissement,
entre Blanche et Barbès,
et qui est ma vision à moi
de la société française,
qui est donc une société
mélangée, multiethnique,
et c'est ce qui fait
toute sa richesse.
Moi, j'ai jamais souffert du racisme
mais j'ai beaucoup d'amis
qui en ont souffert,
et c'est quelque chose qui m'a
toujours porté, touché et interpelé.
Je me souviens d'avoir,
ma passion étant le théâtre,
d'aller à la fois
découvrir des oeuvres, ado,
de Peter Brook,
Ariane Mnouchkine,
qui eux-mêmes mettaient des castings
divers, variés,
venant de chaque pays,
chaque univers,
qui avaient une grande inclusion,
et d'aller aussi découvrir
des oeuvres dans le théâtre privé
où, sur scène et dans la salle,
y avait pas de personnes racisées,
y avait que des blancs,
et ça me choquait
parce que c'était pas
ma vision de la France.
Donc, depuis le début,
j'essaie d'avoir
des acteurs qui sont
d'origines diverses.
-Justement,
on se posait la question,
c'est des anciens migrants,
des migrants
ou des vrais comédiens ?
-C'est des acteurs.
C'est vrai, ça aurait pu.
Ce sont des comédiens
que je connais pour la plupart.
Ils sont sept,
cinq avec qui j'ai déjà travaillé,
trois sur "Intramuros",
deux sur "Le Porteur d'histoire",
et deux nouveaux,
Kevin Razy et Manda Touré.
-Tous d'horizons différents.
-Oui,
mais qui sont tous des comédiens
et comédiennes,
et c'est assez joli.
C'est une troupe multiculturelle,
Jean-Louis est martiniquais,
Ysmahane est marocaine,
Fayçal aussi,
Manda est d'origine malienne,
chacun amène
ses origines.
Voir une troupe aussi diverse
sur une scène de théâtre privée
aussi belle que la Renaissance,
c'est quelque chose de suffisamment
rare pour en être fier.
-C'est une pièce
politiquement engagée.
Vous l'assumez, de faire un peu
de la politique, quelque part ?
-Moi, j'ai toujours dit
que j'étais pas un militant.
J'ai l'impression d'enfoncer
des portes ouvertes dès que je dis
quelque chose de politique.
Après, j'ai toujours été de gauche,
ça a toujours été mes convictions.
Ma pensée politique est claire,
l'endroit où je me situe est clair.
Il se trouve que ce sujet-là,
forcément, me pousse
à me positionner à un moment.
Ce qui est presque terrible,
ironique et paradoxal,
c'est que ce que je raconte
dans cette pièce,
pour tous mes potes
de ma génération,
c'est pas de révolutionnaire,
c'est quelque chose
de simple et d'acquis.
Tous les comédiens de mon âge,
on fait partie
à peu près de la même mouvance,
globalement à gauche,
et donc, il y a quelque chose
où pour nous, c'est pas fou,
mais il y a 20 ans, quand Jean-Marie
Le Pen passait au second tour,
on était un million dans les rues.
Aujourd'hui,
chaque élection,
on a le RN qui passe
comme une fleur au 2e tour
et qui grignote
chaque fois des voix.
On a la mémoire courte.
-Vous voulez faire des spectacles,
des mises en scène
qui soient plus engagées ?
-Non, c'est pas ça.
Chaque oeuvre a sa propre identité.
-C'est le hasard
que ce soit tombé
en plein débat sur l'immigration
au Parlement ?
-J'ai eu l'idée il y a 3 ans,
je l'ai écrite il y a un an
et elle sort...
-Ca résonne avec l'actualité.
-J'espère que la pièce
va durer longtemps et surtout...
J'espère que cette loi
ne va pas passer,
c'est une autre histoire,
mais surtout,
je pense que c'est un sujet
qui est presque éternel.
Plus récent,
parce que les grandes migrations,
ça commence au 19e siècle,
et surtout,
on a eu dans les années 70
toute l'immigration
nord-africaine
qui a changé le visage de la France.
Dans les années 50,
il y avait l'immigration polonaise,
italienne, belge,
mais donc européenne
et qui se voyait moins,
et le racisme était
peut-être moins fort.
Néanmoins, mon père a grandi
dans les années 50 dans le Nord,
c'était "les sales Polaks"
et "les sales Ritals".
Il y avait déjà ce racisme.
-Michel Rocard disait :
"On ne peut pas accueillir
"toute la misère du monde."
Vous êtes d'accord avec ça ?
-Cette phrase est citée
dans la pièce. Jeanne,
le personnage, répond :
"C'est pas vraiment
la misère du monde,
"les pays pauvres
envoient leurs travailleurs
"les plus qualifiés et on pourrait
certainement en accueillir plus."
On a 10 % d'immigrés en France.
La moyenne de l'OCDE, Europe et USA,
c'est 13 %.
Canada et Australie, 20 %.
Donc, on en est loin.
-Vous regrettez
que le RN monte,
mais il monte en partie
à cause de la politique migratoire.
Vous trouvez que l'immigration
est bien gérée, bien contrôlée
en France ?
-Encore une fois,
je me réfère à ce que je raconte
dans la pièce,
je suis un auteur,
donc ma parole est là.
Je vais reciter
ce que je dis.
Moi, je pense
que le vrai coupable,
c'est l'Etat
et sa politique d'intégration
déplorable.
Depuis toujours, pas là récemment.
On a toujours eu
des choix qui étaient terribles
et qui n'ont fait
que continuer
à diviser l'opinion.
La politique migratoire,
si elle était meilleure,
mieux pensée, plus accueillante,
plus intégrante...
-Vous dites plus d'immigrés ?
-Oui.
Je dis mieux intégrés,
mieux accueillis.
Oui, plus d'immigrés,
on est condamnés
à avoir plus d'immigrés.
Sinon, on n'aura pas de quoi payer
les retraites dans 20 ans.
L'immigration est
une source positive.
Mais pour moi,
le coeur du problème,
ça n'est pas une question
d'immigration,
c'est une question
d'iniquité sociale.
Pour moi, c'est le coeur
de tous les problèmes.
Ca devrait être, à mon sens,
hors débat
sur l'écologie et la planète,
que je mets dans une case à part,
mais ça devrait être
le seul sujet qui devrait
être traité tout le temps, H24,
pour tout le monde.
C'est la source de tous les maux,
l'iniquité sociale.
Tout le reste,
c'est de la tartufferie,
des procédés politiques
pour dire :
"Ne parlons pas d'équité sociale,
parlons des immigrés.
"Que pensez-vous des immigrés ?
"Laissez cours à votre racisme,
"parlons plutôt des conflits,
de Gérard Depardieu
"et faisons passer la loi
immigration discrètement."
L'iniquité sociale
ne vient pas des immigrés
mais de cette politique,
qui fait qu'ils sont condamnés
à mettre deux ou trois générations
avant de pouvoir espérer
une amélioration
de leurs conditions.
L'iniquité sociale,
c'est ce qui fait que la pauvreté
et que les écarts de richesses
s'accroissent,
et quand ils s'accroissent,
la grogne monte, la colère monte.
Et aujourd'hui,
le RN récupère le vote ouvrier.
-Délaissé par la gauche.
-Oui, bien sûr.
Et alors,
on a des écarts de richesses
de plus en plus importants,
y a plus de gauche pour fédérer
et y a personne pour dire :
"Le problème,
"ce serait pas juste de mieux
répartir les richesses,
"d'avoir moins de colère
et d'avoir une société plus juste
"et plus intégrante envers
les minorités les plus atteintes ?"
Pour moi, c'est des choses
qui me semblent évidentes.
Et pourtant...
-C'était pour
la partie politique. On va parler
maintenant du Dry January,
qui touche à sa fin.
Vous allez pouvoir ressortir
les bouteilles d'alcool,
à moins que vous ne décidiez
de ne plus y toucher.
Si la consommation d'alcool baisse,
près de 24 % des 18-25 ans dépassent
les repères de consommation.
On met les pieds dans le plat.
Une nouvelle tendance :
les sobreliers.
Ils remplacent les sommeliers
et prônent la sobriété,
donc pas d'alcool,
mêlent des boissons
à base de plantes ou de fruits
et attirent de nouveaux adeptes
avec des dégustations
d'un nouveau genre.
Hélène Bonduelle
et Marion Devauchelle
ont tenté l'expérience.
-Ce sobreuvage accompagne
la première séquence.
Là, il s'agit de l'eau
de cacahuète grillée
et pomme fermentée.
-C'est surprenant et très bon.
-C'est beaucoup moins fort
que ce que je pensais.
C'est bon.
-2e sobreuvage,
percolation de sarrasin grillé.
-Ce soir-là,
les clients de ce restaurant
expérimentent un menu dégustation
un peu spécial.
Un accord mets
et boissons non alcoolisées.
-En général, on a tout de suite
un peu d'acidité
ou une note un peu plus haute
du vin par rapport au plat.
Là non, c'est vraiment le plat qui
est exhalé par rapport à la boisson.
-C'est un choix
de faire le Dry January,
j'ai choisi un restaurant
qui nous accompagne
dans ce parcours.
-Ces breuvages, c'est Benoît
d'Onofrio lui-même qui les élabore.
Des fermentations, des macérations
de fruits et céréales, des infusions
de légumes, de pains et d'épices.
Sommelier depuis 13 ans,
il est devenu ce qu'il appelle
un "sobrelier".
-Il m'est apparu
de plus en plus insupportable
d'être une figure de restaurant
exclusive à une portion de gens
qui peuvent boire de l'alcool,
sachant que depuis que je fais
ce métier,
j'ai toujours été confronté
à des personnes
qui ne buvaient pas d'alcool,
et je n'avais pas
prêté attention à elles.
-Une clientèle
de plus en plus nombreuse.
Le marché des boissons sans alcool
a augmenté de 13 % l'an dernier.
-Je peux vous renseigner ?
-J'aimerais le Sauvignon.
Je vais essayer.
-Cette boutique propose
500 références de boissons
toutes sans aucun alcool.
-Vous avez les cocktails à faire
vous-même, gin, Spritz,
rhum, amaretto,
plein de créations
à base de plantes ou autres.
-Je viens chercher un cadeau
pour un ami
qui boit un peu trop d'alcool.
Il sera content d'avoir
une bonne bouteille sans alcool.
C'est du plaisir
sans la gueule de bois après.
-Mais ces boissons
ont-elles vraiment bon goût ?
Comme ce vin blanc désalcoolisé,
par exemple.
-Je suis assez surprise.
Y a pas la longueur en bouche
mais la première gorgée,
ça ressemble pas mal
à une version originale.
-Vous pourriez être tentés
de faire un repas avec ce vin ?
-Oh oui.
-Oui.
Ca pourrait être une expérience.
-Peut-être, si ça me permettait
de boire moins d'alcool,
faire un transfert,
tout en ayant le plaisir,
mais baisser ma consommation
d'alcool, ça serait une bonne chose.
-C'était mon idée, à la base.
J'ai plus envie de boire d'alcool
mais j'aime aller dans les bars,
sortir avec des amis,
et on est toujours limité à un jus
de fruit, à des sodas super sucrés.
Et surtout, proposer
un nouveau récit, sortir
du sans alcool un peu triste,
limité à la sécurité routière.
-Et le concept fonctionne.
Le patron envisage même
d'ouvrir de nouvelles boutiques
en France.
-Vous, Alexis Michalik,
les accords mets-vin
sans vin, vous connaissez puisque
vous êtes "dry" toute l'année.
-Je suis zéro alcool, oui.
-Ca vous tente, ces concoctions ?
-On va goûter.
Ca, moyen.
J'aime pas le vin.
-C'est du vin,
on le voyait dans le reportage,
du vin blanc désalcoolisé.
-Ouais, très bien.
-Pas plus que ça ?
-J'aime pas le vin.
-Mais y a pas d'alcool !
Mais y a l'odeur.
-C'est pas l'alcool,
c'est le goût du vin.
-Après, en bouche...
-Celui-là, on y va.
-Là, c'est autre chose.
C'est le sobrelier
qui l'a concocté.
Y a du clou de girofle !
Dégustation.
-Y a beaucoup de clou de girofle.
-Ca se sent.
-C'est une concoction
à base de clous de girofle.
-C'est censé accompagner
du couscous.
-D'accord. Très bien.
-Il faut le voir accord mets-vin.
Mets-boisson, pardon.
-Faut aimer le clou de girofle,
quoi.
Vraiment l'aimer beaucoup.
-Je suis assez
de son avis pour le clou de girofle,
c'est un peu trop pour moi.
Je préfère le vin,
à la rigueur.
A consommer
avec modération !
-Je peux attaquer le dessert ?
-C'est intéressant,
ce renouveau du sans alcool.
De voir ces vins.
-Vous vous sentez moins seul
en soirée !
-Moi qui suis sans alcool,
je vois très bien ce qu'il veut dire
quand il dit :
"Dans les bars,
on boit quoi ?"
On a assez peu de choix.
Moi, je serais pro
infusions et thés.
C'est le mieux.
-Mais en soirée,
quand vous allez boire un verre ?
-Je ne vais pas boire un verre.
-Pas même pour prendre un thé ?
-Si, mais y a pas de thés.
Enfin, le thé chaud.
Mais il faudrait toute une gamme
de thés froids, c'est très facile
à produire et ça coûte pas cher.
-Vous êtes pour développer
ces nouveaux thés.
-Oui, et sans sucres,
c'est le plus important.
-Tout le monde a fini,
on passe au dessert.
C'est le péché mignon.
-J'attaque.
-On va aller très vite.
Alexis voulait
une salade de fruits.
Il y a des kiwis,
des petits raisins, des pommes.
Vous n'aimez pas les desserts,
les gâteaux ?
Vous parliez des baklavas,
j'aurais préféré
que vous nous les fassiez goûter.
-C'est pas pour vous, Jean-Pierre.
-J'aime trop les desserts.
-Ah, c'est pour ça !
-J'essaie de me maintenir
dans un mode de vie,
un niveau de poids correct.
-C'est le "dry" jusqu'au dessert.
-J'essaie d'éviter le sucre.
-Vous aimez beaucoup les desserts,
en fait !
-Oui, bien sûr, justement.
Et depuis janvier,
je fais ma cure sans sucre.
Les fructoses,
oui, pourquoi pas.
-Si vous avez le droit,
on oublie le "dry",
qu'est-ce que vous aimez
comme desserts ?
-Tout. La profiterole, les baklavas,
les pâtisseries marocaines,
tout, quoi.
On a la chance de vivre en France.
Dans chaque boulangerie,
on a à peu près
tout ce qu'il nous faut.
J'aime tout le sucre, moi.
Je peux manger des cookies,
j'en amenais à mes comédiens
pendant les répétitions,
mais après, on est tous mal,
en souffrance.
-Quel est votre secret ?
Vous êtes fit.
-La salade de fruits !
-C'est bien, après un couscous.
Il a raison.
-C'est quand même mieux.
-Même si les fruits, il vaut mieux
les consommer entre les repas
qu'à la fin d'un repas.
Sinon, ils fermentent un peu
et ils se digèrent moins bien.
-On termine toujours en musique.
Vous avez choisi celle-là.
"Trying To Breathe", Sly Johnson
...
-Trying to breathe
I dream of a quiet place
L'histoire de cette musique
a un lien avec "Passeport".
C'est Sly Johnson,
un musicien émérite, talentueux,
beat-boxeur, qui touche à tout
et qui était un ancien
du Saïan Supa Crew.
Je l'ai vu faire à l'occasion
des musiques de pièces
et je lui ai proposé de faire
la musique de "Passeport".
Il a lu le texte et m'a dit oui.
Il était avec nous
en répétition tous les jours et il a
composé toute la BO de "Passeport".
-En regardant vos répétitions.
-Oui.
Ca, c'est la chanson finale
qui monte
sur les 5 dernières minutes
et qui arrive
jusqu'aux applaudissements.
Je pense qu'il va la mettre bientôt
en ligne sur une plateforme.
-On va se quitter
sur cette belle chanson,
cette belle musique.
Merci, Alexis Michalik,
d'avoir accepté notre invitation.
Merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis.
Merci, Jean-Pierre.
On se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...